[Musique]
tous les acteurs majeurs de la
protection de l'enfance étaient présents
à l'hémicycle du département
lorsque ce public fragile pousse les
portes de la protection de l'enfance les
situations sont extrêmement complexes
raison pour laquelle l'état la rs les
institutions judiciaires et le
département doivent créer un outil de
travail collectif l'observatoire
permettra à la fois de faire des bilans
qualitatif que quantitatif est également
de nous donner des axes de travail les
améliorations collectivement et c'est au
coeur de cette instance que les jeunes
pourront aussi s'exprimer dire ce qu'ils
ressentent comment ils voient les choses
comment ils sentent aussi l'impact des
politiques qui sont les nôtres et
comment nous collectivement on peut les
écouter les entendre et améliorer ce
qu'on fait 120 millions d'euros sont
consacrés chaque année à la mission de
protection de l'enfance et de la famille
une action sociale souvent dans l'ombre
est pourtant essentiel localement
sachant que le nombre de jeunes
bénéficiaires a augmenté de 6% ces
dernières années l'accompagnement de
l'enfance en danger est une compétence
légale fixée par la loi
mais au delà de ça nous devons agir le
devons aller de l'avant et c'est ce que
nous faisons
parce que dans une société comme celle
de la réunion vous avez une jeunesse en
difficulté
vous avez aussi une population
vieillissante vous avez parfois des
situations de violence intrafamiliale le
département de l'arrêté en date est très
présent c'est ce que nous faisons et la
mise en place de cet observatoire
ben va nous permettre de développer le
partenariat avec tous les acteurs en
cohérence avec une stratégie nationale
de prévention et de protection de
l'enfance 2020 2022
cet observatoire intitulé au dpe
permettra une approche plus humaine plus
approprié plus efficace qui prendra en
compte ce qui est vécu par certains de
nos jeunes
[Musique]